Well if you would please turn with me to the book of Exodus. We've been going through this book as a church family
and we are nearing the end of our series.
And we're going to be looking today in Exodus 33 and 34.
Exodus 33 and 34.
It's also there in your worship guide if you'd like to look there if you've not got a Bible with you.
We'll begin reading in verse 18 with Moses' request here.
Moses said, Please show me your glory.
And he said, I will make all my goodness pass before you and will proclaim before you my name, the Lord.
And I will be gracious to whom I will be gracious and I will show mercy on whom I will show mercy.
But he said, You cannot see my face for man shall not see my face and live.
The Lord said, Behold there is a place by me where you shall stand on the rock.
And while my glory passes by I will put you in a cleft of the rock and I will cover you with my hand until I have passed by.
Then I will take away my hand and you shall see my back but my face shall not be seen.
The Lord said to Moses, Cut for yourselves two tablets of stone like the first.
And I will write on the tablets the words that were on the first tablets which you broke.
Be ready by the morning and come up in the morning to Mount Sinai and present yourself there to me on the top of the mountain.
No one shall come up with you and let no one be seen throughout all the mountain.
Let no flocks or herds graze opposite that mountain.
So Moses cut two tablets of stone like the first.
And he rose early in the morning and went up on Mount Sinai as the Lord had commanded him and took in his hands two tablets of stone.
The Lord descended in the cloud and stood with him there and proclaimed the name of the Lord.
The Lord passed before him and proclaimed, The Lord, the Lord, a God merciful and gracious,
slow to anger and abounding in steadfast love and faithfulness, keeping steadfast love for thousands,
forgiving iniquity and transgression and sin, but who will by no means clear the guilty,
visiting the iniquity of the fathers on their children and the children's children to the third and fourth generation.
And Moses quickly bowed his head toward the earth and worshiped.
And he said, If now I have found favor in your sight, O Lord, please let the Lord go in the midst of us for it is a stiff-necked people
and pardon our iniquity and our sin and take us for your inheritance.
This is the word of the Lord.
Let's pray.
Well, we thank you so much for the gift of your word.
We also thank you for the gift of your spirit who opens our eyes to see you in your word.
And so Lord, I pray that you would open our eyes now to see more of Jesus.
We pray this in his name.
Amen.
Well, on Valentine's Day, Julia and I went to go see a movie called Solo Mio.
I don't know if anybody else saw that one.
It was pretty good.
The premise of the film is that there is this engaged couple who's booked a kind of two-for-one, all-inclusive wedding and honeymoon trip in Italy.
So you go there and you kind of, you're there with a group and you have the wedding ceremony.
And then after that, you've got all of these kind of couples' excursions all across Italy.
But there is a problem.
The bride to be decides not to go through with the wedding.
And the husband to be is left standing there on the altar.
So the groom faces this dilemma.
What should he do about this trip?
It was never meant to be alone.
Does he go it solo or not?
So it's a really kind of sad start to the movie.
Well, this is the dilemma in some ways.
We are coming across here in Exodus 33.
But what we're reading here is far worse.
God tells Moses, when you look at the start of chapter 33, that it's time to depart from Mount Sinai and for the people to make their way to the promised land.
He tells them that an angel is going to go before them and is going to drive out their enemies.
He tells them that the land that they are going to enter is a land full of abundance.
It's a land flowing with milk and honey.
But there is a problem.
Here's the problem.
God himself is not going to be going with them.
The trip was going to have to be a solo trip.
They'd have to go it alone.
Now, God has good reasons to not go with them.
They have been unfaithful to him.
Only days after they made their covenant vows before the Lord, they forsook him and began to worship and idol instead.
We saw that last week with the worshiping of the golden calf.
But God's refusal to go with them wasn't him giving them what they deserved because of their idolatry.
Rather, it was a mercy.
He's actually withholding judgment.
Here's what he says in chapter 33 verse 3.
He says, I won't go up with you lest I consume you on the way.
In other words, his holy presence would have meant their destruction.
So by not going, he's actually withholding judgment from them.
That's not how it felt.
It feels like they're having to go it alone.
This is devastating news.
And the journey that they were on wasn't ultimately about the land.
It was about, as we've seen time and time again, this is about their relationship with their redeemer.
He saved them that they might know him, that they might walk in his ways and that they might be with him.
Moses knew this.
You know, Moses also knew that God had shown him favor.
He knew that it was the Lord's grace, that he had made this people his own people.
And so he prays, Moses comes before the Lord and prays that the Lord would remain with them.
He would go with them on the way to the promised land.
And so wonderfully, the Lord agrees to show them even more of the riches of his mercy and continue with them on the journey.
But Moses doesn't finish there.
God says, okay, I'll be with you and I'll show you mercy along the way.
But Moses says, I want one more thing.
And that's where we get to what we read just a moment ago.
Moses prays, please show me your glory.
That's where we're going to be focusing our attention this morning, this bold request.
Yes, you're coming with us, but show me even more of your glory.
And as we look at this, I want us to be reminded that we were created to know the Lord, to live in relationship with him, to be with him forever.
And not only that, we were meant to see and savor his glory.
The Lord saves us with that purpose in view that we might see and know him for who he truly is and be satisfied in him.
So this morning we are being invited to join Moses in this prayer.
To pray, Lord, please show me your glory.
So what we're going to do is we're going to look at Moses' request and what it's all about.
And we're going to see how God responds to that with all of us praying the same thing, hopefully.
So let's look at this request. What do we learn from that request itself? Please show me your glory.
First of all, it's a request for revelation.
Show me your glory.
So Moses is asking God to reveal something about himself, namely his glory.
But what does that even mean? We keep saying this word glory. What are we talking about here?
Well, glory, God's glory isn't like one of his attributes alongside all of his others.
The Bible talks about God's glory. It's talking about the splendor of all that he is.
It's the radiance of his manifold perfections.
It is the stunning beauty of his very being.
It's called glory.
And the fact is we are hardwired to be drawn to things like that. We are attracted to glorious things.
This is why we enjoy going to things like a concert or like a professional sporting event
and seeing a team doing really well. We're drawn into that or going to a national park
and seeing the grandeur of that. And this could go on.
We have a hunger to see glory.
But this here is pointing us to a far greater and all satisfying glory that we were made to know.
I love how Paul David Tripp describes our desire to behold glory.
It's almost been like a spiritual GPS that God has built into us.
Like we want to see glory. And it's because God has built us into us so that we look ultimately to him.
It points us to our Creator.
So how can we see God's glory? It must be revealed.
It's God's to show.
You see, the glory of God isn't something that we merely like figure out with our own intellect by studying more.
It's not something that we kind of just feel our way towards, you know, with our own like spiritual intuition
or something along those lines. Rather, it's something that God gives.
It's a gift from him revealing his glory.
So Moses knew that it was God's initiative to come and make himself known to him, for example, at the burning bush.
It was God's initiative to come down on Mount Sinai to make himself known and to give his word there.
So it must be God who can reveal more of his glory to Moses.
By the way, to say that it's God who does this isn't a call to passivity in this either.
Note this. Moses is praying for this revelation.
God invites us to seek after him and he calls us to seek after him.
So Moses is praying, God show me your glory.
And this is what we should be praying and seeking after as well.
Because God is pleased to answer this prayer.
So reveals who God is, his glory.
But it's also revealing something about Moses, particularly his heart.
Moses desires.
So what is this telling us about Moses desires that this is what he prays?
This, it's telling us this. That Moses desires God more than anything else.
You see, the most important thing in his life is his relationship with God.
So this is what he prays for. This is the top of his list.
He wants the Lord himself.
You know, when he was told that God would not be going with them to the promised land,
Moses said this to him. He says, if your presence will not go with us, I don't want to go.
So offer Moses a good life of overflowing abundance without the Lord.
And he's not interested.
He would far rather have the hardship and homelessness of the desert and know the Lord in the midst of it.
He would rather know the Lord in hardship than a picture perfect life without the Lord.
You see, Moses' desire, he knows that what he needs is in the Lord himself.
And when God granted Moses requests to remain with them, Moses was no doubt delighted.
But you know, he doesn't say, well, thank you very much. Looking forward to you being with us.
He says, I want to know even more.
So he knows the Lord.
And the sign that he knows the Lord is he wants to know the Lord even more.
This is an indication that someone has truly tasted and seen that the Lord is good.
Because when you've tasted and seen that he is good, you thirst for more of him.
Because his glory is greater than anything in the world.
This is what the apostle Paul described when he said, I count, and this is Philippians 3.8.
He said, I count everything is lost compared to the surpassing worth of knowing Christ Jesus my Lord.
So the worth of Jesus is far surpassing anything else in this world.
So let me just apply this personally.
What has the gaze of your heart this morning?
What is it that you are desiring?
What's filling your mind and your affections?
Let's bring it to exactly where we are this morning.
One way to consider whether or not God himself is truly our heart's desire
is to consider why we've come to church.
Why are we here?
People come to church for a lot of reasons.
And good reasons.
People think, as we've seen this morning, it's a good environment to raise their children in.
There's a good way of life that's put before us.
There are lots of benefits we could think of.
We're stars for friendships.
This is a good place to make friends.
But the heart check that we all need is this.
Are we here mostly because we want God's gifts or because we want God himself?
Now don't get me wrong.
We praise God for his gifts.
We thank him for them.
We seek after it.
But above and beyond all of that, our supreme desire, the supreme desire of our hearts should be God in seeing his glory.
The Lord working us in such a way that like Moses we would say, I'd rather live in the desert with the Lord than in paradise without him.
One day the hymn writer, Fanny Crosby, heard a neighbor of hers complaining that he didn't have enough money to do what he was wanting to do.
And here she was blind from infancy.
And she couldn't do near the stuff that he could already do even without the money.
But she started thinking about what she had in Jesus was far greater than anything in the world that she could have without him.
So she started writing down this hymn.
She wrote this.
She wrote, Take the world but give me Jesus.
Let me view his constant smile.
Then throughout this life's long journey he will lead me all the while.
Take the world but give me Jesus.
In his cross my trust shall be till with clearer, brighter vision, face to face my Lord I see.
That's what it sounds like for the Lord himself to have captivated someone's heart.
This revelation of glory hopefully will lead us to pray the same thing.
To ask the Lord to make himself known to us.
To give us a greater desire for him and to fulfill that desire by showing us more of himself.
Alright, so that's the request.
Now secondly, let's look at the response to that request.
Here we see God is pleased to grant what Moses has asked for.
But he also reframes it slightly.
Look now at verse 19.
And he said, I will make all my, doesn't say glory, I will make all my goodness pass before you.
And will proclaim before you my name.
So God is going to show Moses more of his glory but he reframes that as goodness and his name.
It's interesting when we think of glory, we don't automatically always think of goodness.
We think of things that are big and grand.
So it's interesting that the Lord uses the word goodness to describe his glory.
We'll perhaps return to that in a moment.
But God is revealing his glorious goodness in at least a couple of ways here.
God is going to show Moses his glory but he's also going to speak to Moses about his glory.
He says, I'm going to cause my goodness to pass before you and I'm going to proclaim my name.
So imagine, I don't know, like seeing a beautiful sunset and you're looking out at the sky standing next to somebody
and all you know to say is, wow, that's what's going through your mind, wow.
And this person beside you, they're looking at that same sunset
and they're thinking about exactly what is going on scientifically and they're in awe and wonder about that.
And then all of a sudden they start thinking about the specific colors that are there in front of them
and that leads to them crafting this beautiful poem in their mind
with the perfect analogies about what they're seeing.
Now both of you are seeing the same thing.
But one of them is seeing a little more detail than what you're seeing.
So you get a similar thing here.
There's this kind of wow factor of like this is who God is.
Moses is not left to interpret what he is seeing.
Moses says, God says, here I am and this is who I am specifically.
Okay, this is what's going on here.
So he passes by Moses.
Now it says nobody can look directly at God's being and live.
So God puts him in the cleft of a rock and he covers him with his hand until he passes by
and he allows him to see his back.
Now this is mysterious, this kind of revelation of God, but nonetheless it is good.
This is really happening here.
But then so that's what Moses is seeing.
That's that kind of wow.
But then God proclaims his name.
Now remember as we've seen already in Exodus, his name is the revelation of his nature.
So the Lord emphatically repeats his name.
This is the very name I am who I am.
It says the Lord, the Lord.
This is the name that he revealed to Moses earlier on in the book of Exodus.
So this isn't just information that the Lord is imparting here.
This isn't just like a theology course or something.
This is his very identity that he's putting before Moses here and now it's through the word.
Now this is a major moment in the Old Testament.
Now of course this is a book about who God is.
Here he gives this statement about his nature and it's going to be repeated throughout the Old Testament.
You see it in places like Psalm 103.
You see it in the book of Nehemiah, the book of Jonah.
We could go on and list all these examples.
This is a foundational statement, almost like a creed that says this is who our God is.
This is who the Lord is.
And that's then expounded even further in the New Testament.
What God says about himself begins with what he says about his character.
He says a God, when he proclaims his name, he says,
the Lord the Lord, a God merciful and gracious,
slow to anger and abounding in steadfast love and faithfulness.
So what is the very first thing God wants us to know about who he is like?
What is this statement front loaded with?
The fact that he is merciful and gracious.
He is merciful.
This is telling us that his heart is full of compassion,
especially for his children.
He is gracious.
He is freely, he's a God who freely and abundantly gives good gifts
because this is who he is, it's the overflow of his gracious nature because he's a God of grace.
He's slow to anger.
This is speaking of God's patience.
It's not to say that God is totally without anger.
There's a thing called righteous anger, which is right to be angry at certain things.
But God is slow to anger in that he doesn't have a short fuse.
He's so patient with us.
He is long suffering towards us.
We saw that as the Lord provided water and food for his complaining people in the wilderness time and time again.
You see this in the New Testament, 2 Peter 3.9.
It says the Lord is not slow concerning his promise.
Some people count slowness, but is long suffering to usward, not willing that any should perish,
but that all should come to repentance.
In other words, why has the Lord not returned?
Because he is long suffering, waiting to bring all of those who will come to him in repentance to himself.
And he's a God who is abounding in steadfast love and faithfulness.
It's just speaking about God's covenant keeping love.
His faithfulness is his rock solid commitment to his people and his promises.
And it is boundless. It is immeasurable.
That's his character.
But he then goes to talk about his actions that flows from his character.
That's what he says next. He says in verse 7, keeping steadfast love.
This is Exodus 34, 7 by the way.
Keeping steadfast love for thousands, forgiving iniquity and transgression and sin.
Paul's there. So God keeps steadfast love.
He guards it, he maintains it. For who? For thousands.
That's not just a reference to thousands of people.
If you go to Deuteronomy 7.9, it explicitly says it's for thousands of generations.
So it's implied here, but it's specific there in Deuteronomy.
That's what he's saying here.
This isn't like a mathematical statement as though, like, I'm going to work with a thousand generations.
In a thousand one, I'm done.
It's not a kind of precise statement. It's a statement of abundance.
It's speaking of the largeness of his love.
It's like a flood sweeping through generations, flowing through the centuries,
even to this present day.
This is his love. That's the picture here.
What does that love bring about?
It brings about forgiveness.
That literally means to carry the burden, like carry the burden of our sin.
So if you back out this morning, and as I've done before, not here, but back out and hit a car,
some, you're wondering about my driving now, somebody's going to pay for that.
Like either the person who backed into the car or like, you're going to have to take that burden on yourself.
So when God's saying, he forgives sin, sin still has to be dealt with.
I overlook sin. I'm going to turn to by and die to sin.
It's more that he carries the burden himself.
He takes that burden on himself.
And on the flip side here, we also see that God is not just loving and forgiving.
He's also the God who will by no means clear the guilty,
visiting the iniquities of the fathers on the children
and the children's children to the third and fourth generation.
So to speak of God's mercy and grace and love in such glowing terms is not to say that he's soft.
He takes sin seriously. He's a God who does punish the guilty.
This is why I'm, the pastor Mark Devere refers to this passage as the great riddle of the Old Testament.
It really is a great paradox.
It's like how can God be both just and loving at the same time?
We'll return to that in a moment.
But to add to the tension of his justice and his love,
you then had this part about him visiting the sins of the fathers on the children to the third and fourth generation.
Happy Mother's Day.
What a verse to get to Child Dedication Sunday.
Sadly, it is true and tragic that sinful patterns and consequences that go with those patterns often do continue on from generation to generation.
I don't have to convince you of that. We see it.
That's one of the reasons why we included not just children, but parents in this time of dedication this morning in the church as well.
As we look to the Lord together in this.
But you know there's a great comfort in what he says here too.
Where's that comfort found in?
It's kind of found in the numbers once again.
So God deals with sin, it says, to the third and the fourth generation.
But don't forget the number that's coming up behind that third and fourth.
What was it?
It was the number a thousand.
He shows his love to the thousandth generation.
So do you see the difference? You see what's going on here?
So yes, the consequences of sin are real and devastating.
But the love of God and the powerful work that he accomplishes through it is far greater.
God's people might have run from him in their idolatry.
And it was wrong, of course it was.
But a tidal wave of mercy is heading their way.
We already see the evidence even of this here.
We want to look into all of it, but here we have God renewing the covenant and restoring his relationship with his people.
You see this in Isaiah 54, verses seven and eight.
God says this.
He says, for a brief moment I deserted you, but with great compassion I will gather you.
In overflowing anger for a moment I hid my face from you.
But with everlasting love I will have compassion on you.
The goodness of God.
The glory revealed here, yes, is like a tidal wave flowing through generations,
even sweeping through the whole world,
gathering a people for the glory of his name from every tribe, tongue and nation.
Yes, sin abounds, but grace does much more abound.
You know, to apply this personally, yes, your sin and mine is serious and deserving of judgment,
but it is no match for God's grace.
God can break through your life in a way that impacts you, bringing you to himself,
that impacts your family, and even impacts generations to come.
This is the glory that is being revealed here.
But the final thing I want to say is this is the glory that is being revealed in Jesus.
When Jesus' disciples reflected on their time with Jesus, I think Caleb mentioned this last week.
They said this, John 1.14,
we beheld his glory, the glory as of the only begotten of the Father, full of grace and truth.
Jesus himself says in John 17.6 that he revealed God's name.
Do you want to see God's name proclaimed? His nature put before us, it's in the person of Jesus.
The author of Hebrews, Hebrews 1.3 says that Jesus is the radiance of the glory of God
and the exact representation of his being.
So God's glory, the radiance of his splendor, the beauty of his being is seen in the person of his son.
All of God's perfections dwell in Jesus, the eternal Son of God.
On Mount Sinai, Moses caught a glimpse of God's glory, but you and I are invited to gaze upon his glory in the face of Jesus Christ.
We can see God's glory by the power of the Spirit when we fix our eyes by faith on Jesus Christ.
Because it's in Jesus Christ that the answer of that riddle of the Old Testament is found.
So how can God be merciful and just? Because Jesus, the very embodiment of his glory,
took our sin upon himself, took our guilt upon himself and died in our place.
How can God forgive sin? So he takes that burden on himself. What does he do with it? How does God pay for our sin?
Because Jesus took that burden and he paid the cost when he died for us on Calvary.
So where do we see God's glorious goodness, his mercy, his grace, his loving kindness shining most brightly?
What is that? The cross. It is there that we see the mercy, grace and the love of God.
See that he, in Jesus, was willing to lay aside heaven's glory to be clothed in flesh and died to make us his own.
So yes, the greatest blessing in life is not God's gifts, those are the things that we might be desiring this morning.
The greatest blessing is God himself and God has given himself to us.
He's offering himself to us even today in the person of Jesus Christ.
So when we pray, please show me your glory. He shows us Jesus.
So how should we respond? We should join Moses in praying that we might see more of him.
Let's be a people who do that. If you've never seen his glory, pray that you might see his glory.
If you've seen his glory a hundred times, you know there's more to see. Keep seeking after him.
And then gaze upon his glory in Jesus. You might see more and more of him.
And then like Moses, chapter 34 and verse 8, fall before him in worship.
See the more we see of God's goodness in Jesus, the more we adore him and the more we will gladly offer up our lives to him because he's worthy.
He is good. He is glorious. Let's pray.
Lord, I pray that you would open our eyes to see more of your glory in the face of Jesus Christ.
Lord, so often we get distracted by so many other things as though they were ultimate, as though they were the thing that was going to satisfy the restlessness, hunger, the thirst of our souls.
When all the while it is you and your glory, your glorious goodness that does that, what I pray that you turn our eyes to you.
And Lord, we praise you that you are pleased to make yourself known to us. So we pray, Lord, show us more of your glory. Amen.